the republicans have been sort of like
flirting with russia for quite a while
now which is so interesting to me
because when we were young i mean the
the republican party was so anti-russia
i mean that's how ronald reagan became a
hero the evil empire and all that and we
did an editorial on the show a few years
ago about why did this flip so badly and
i showed some quotes from people and i'd
like them to show them now ann coulter
said in 20 years russia will be the only
country that is recognizably european
matt drudge putin is the leader of the
free world
and uh i think they all got this from
david duke back in 2004 he said uh
russia is the key to white survival and
that was the point i was trying to make
that night and i'm wondering if you
could weigh in on this that like
the world has become a lot more diverse
i talked about how the fact that when i
was in first time i went to london in
the 1980s was a completely white city
and now it's a beautiful diverse city
russia is the one place in the world
that says
yet
to diversity
they you know and i i i closed it by
saying you know it's the rush the
republicans don't see
meddling in our election as a bad thing
they see it as white people helping
white people
and they are just
the people who are afraid of a diverse
world
russia
is their savior country so i think it's
actually a little bit more complicated
than that i think what's going on is
that the republicans are unconsciously
maybe consciously imitating wokeness
because if you really unpack wokeness
wokeness
fundamentally disrespects the sanctity
and the sacredness of the individual it
assumes the lived experiences of people
based upon skin color it encourages the
segregation of people based upon skin
color the republicans in many ways are
responding in kind and they're imitating
that kind of woke
uh
sentiment and so
if we want that to stop it is incumbent
it is even more incumbent upon the
democrats
right to get their act together and say
no to elements of that because the
republican party is seeing that as
something with which to gain power and
to gain influence and so i think in many
ways there's an imitation going on here
and this is this is joe i think that's
such an important insight it's also joe
biden's opportunity to turn around his
presidency and to remind us he is the
leader of the free world and the free
world means something and one of the
things it means is an open society open
to people of every background and skin
color and ethnicity and religion and he
is going to
chant in that world against
against all enemies foreign and domestic
the greatest enemies foreign being mr xi
in china mr putin in russia and domestic
enemies who want to tear this country
apart and turn it into a facsimile of
what they imagine russia to be all right
you